[Music]
there was a mention of a wolf theater
it was just a generalized boogeyman that
kind of popped up in maybe two stories
and just sort of took that word and went
how could someone come up with this
legend what did they see or think they
saw in the woods one time
um and also that element of in eastern
europe as well as in the rest of the
world often women who were accused of
witchcraft were accused of taking the
shape of another human being or an
animal and um
you know if you could do that you're
basically you know you can live multiple
lives in multiple bodies you're kind of
living outside of time and
outside of people really so what a great
perspective and you know life and time
and and this is all really an
instinctive process i'm only trying to
verbalize and intellectualize afterwards
all just kind of comes out as a word
salad onto my laptop at the start um
um or just nodes and you know tissues or
whatever if i'm lying around um but yeah
i think roughly that was the process as
far as i can you know the ritual of the
scratch
and the spitting to turn
the other person in into the witch
it's interesting because i i once i one
time went on a date with a witch
i really did
she had these videos she had made
because she was a shaman and um that is
a real practice in shamanism
the spitting is
there's videos of it there's actually
actually spitting practice it's really
interesting i don't know about the
scratching part but the spitting
practice is real it might expand at this
rate
you need to go on some dates with some
witches
you'll learn so much starting tonight
um
so let's let's talk about your actors
who are
freaking amazing
uh
um some well-known actors um you've got
numerous and um you've got the uh
alice angler who's
j champion's daughter
and uh anna maria marinka
from four months three weeks two days
how did you score all these uh
incredible
people to be in your phone um
semi accidentally across many years
anna maria i've been obsessed with since
i was
20. basically i i saw four months three
weeks two days and it's sort of like
it's one of the great works of art of my
lifetime i feel like it was you know an
almost religious experience and like to
me that is just
that acting could could be that you know
it blew my mind like that was just my
favorite performance and
one of the first features i ever wrote
that had a producer attached the first
person i hunted down was anna maria
marinko that feature never worked out
but we met through that and we've stayed
friends ever since and then um yeah i
didn't really write it thinking about
her but because i wasn't really thinking
of anyone when i wrote it um
but as soon as
you know
i started picturing who could play this
role it was immediately her because i
feel like she can do
very stylized and very raw naturalistic
acting um and
both things feel equally real
um alice englert i met in a talent lab
because as a filmmaker i did not know
who she was whether she was an actress
i remember making it for myself like a
week later at some point drunken at a
party where someone just told me
she's cheating champions do it and just
told her i said i'm like you're jane
champion's daughter
but she forgave me and we're still
friends
uh
and she's in the movie now um
and numi
we met through they have the same agent
her and alice um
that was a very short short list of
actresses
um
who i thought would fit into the world
um
and you know make
financiers happy and make me happy that
i felt were raw and fearless um
i actually don't know who else like i
don't know i think there was a short
list that i came up with that there
wasn't much overlap with other people's
short lists
but now i'm just like i can't remember
anyone other than new me because who
else
could actually i don't want to leave out
sarah klamosca
who's navina who's the first i could
never leave her eyes
first convert yes i was reading that
she'd been working with her for a long
time um she was in my short film uh four
years ago that's when we met um and
yeah i mean anymore right i'm gonna like
she was i knew she would be one of the
roles and hadn't decided on which one it
was sort of like
collecting
people that i connected to who connected
with the script and then sort of see
what they responded to most is sarah
because she's the first uh the one who
does all the voice over as well and also
because the voice
is really amazing as well
um
so let's just talk about working with
them how because you know they had to be
to give such physical performances them
and
the the male actor who i did who i
didn't write down carlotta
who was also amazing
um
how
do you help them get into character and
play a character like this um fluke i
guess i don't know um
look it was a
it was one of those you know i did
everything i could and hoped and prayed
it would work out um essentially and um
it was almost unconscious again an
instinctive process um sarah was the
first one to and the only one of them
who was on set with me five weeks early
and i spent the most time with her and
she was involved in even she came along
to location scouts just kind of getting
lost in the world of it we recorded the
voice over about five weeks before the
shoot
and then that made the character less
abstract um there were directions within
the big print in the script that kind of
charted the progress and sort of hinted
at what the mannerisms could be that
kind of translating how they soften over
time
um and then she
established it
um we said a video reference of a
particular person
um
who grew up tragically in captivity and
was found at age 13. um
and
yeah and then
as the actress came in out of order in
almost random order you know based on
logistics and availability um i'd spoken
to them on skype and sort of you know
painted the story universe for them and
the details of the character and then
sarah would meet them i think the day
they arrived and kind of talked through
what body language is established so
they're aware of it not necessarily so
they copy it
um so then they could build on it
um they will listen to the voice server
they watch the same reference video as
well and then i would bring them into
the village and sort of again steep them
into the world of it
and we gave them a lot of freedom
because i felt like at every
iteration of the characters it's a stage
of evolution and i kind of um i don't
know i don't think what's the point of
bringing new me and carlotta and telling
them to be like someone else i i sort of
what moves me the most is when i see you
know just
the character i wrote and and myself and
sorry but that knew me and then colorado
and it's like in individual moments
someone else is playing the character
but i see all of them in it you know um
and
i also sort of
realized
what i do is i tend to put myself in the
emotional mental state of the character
in the situation i'm directing um i
don't really talk about it it's just you
know for me but i think there is
something symbiotic that happens
um because those two main characters
nevin and maria is my brain split in
half essentially and i'm very intensely
connected to them you know um so
and i think there is something that
translates so i think a lot of the
consistency comes from that as well um
and i
feel very connected to all of them so
they're all present you know i felt like
all through the shoot even if they
weren't physically
in a way that i think is very probably
scientifically explainable i just can't
i'm not an airy fairy person i'm very
practical
person but i do think there is something
to you know humans when you connect um
that yeah
so
uh this has an incredible visual
uh style to it
um
i was trying to think how i would
describe this to someone and i
i was like it's terence malik but with a
little body horror
a little core yeah um
uh
who are your
influences um visually how did you
decide how you wanted the movie to be
shot
um
the principle we were working with was
every every person who came on board and
there were still people coming on board
like two days before we wrapped because
of the nature of the story
i was always saying don't think of it as
any other movie uh specifically think of
it as if a fairy tale was based on a
true story
we're making a documentary of that true
story um
and i mean terence malik came up as a
reference for sure i've been stunned at
how that's by far the you know obviously
the dominant
um name that comes up um and i adore i
worship him you know um completely
um
he certainly came up as a reference in
terms of conversation but we weren't
really
thinking of him that much to the extent
that i remember even like
making comments like oh this is like a
malik shot because it was sort of a joke
not making fun of mal like just making
fun of the notion that me trying to be
like malik how ridiculous
um so then when the comparisons have
started i was like what um and you know
not necessarily in a bad way and then i
watch this movie again and i haven't
seen it in nine months and i'm still
like
my math is bad seven months uh
yeah i i don't really i mean i see some
malik but i see a hundred other things
so i feel like i don't know if there's
other things that i haven't conveyed
that i see
um i see andrea arnold and champion as
much as i see malik or
um all of russian cinema all of european
center from the 60s like i was a film
nerd before i was a filmmaker i'm still
more a film nerd
really
um
shocking
oh it usually comes across to people
quite vividly
um
but yeah i think when you're on set like
i just go what's in front of me and we
did
have some compositional principles but
often we just gave the actors a 360
space to play
um and kept
as much as we could and you know
designed and built the sets as much as
possible and found the location so that
they had room and the camera could float
around them
um but stay very close and sort of
handheld and gritty and shallow focus to
keep the connection and the subjectivity
i'm not really thinking about the
references when i'm directing more
thinking what is she feeling right now
how do i convey that how do i keep
people make people feel like what she is
in that moment
and then i i think you know it all comes
from instinct but instinct is built on
me watching movies for 20 years and and
a lot of teres malik along the way so
possibly other people might know this
the answer to this question better than
me it might be more obvious to me in a
few years
but yeah
i keep i keep thinking about the end of
the film
and um
i don't want to make you explain like
themes of this movie or or anything like
that but basically what you know maria
says at the end of the movie is i don't
understand why it was so easy for you
what if anything
did you
what was you know what if anything was
the difference between maria and novina
um
did maria do something wrong
no no no sir to me it's um
they both
um were born like you know came into a
world that had these borders
limits around them
and they tried to live as full of life
as possible
they wanted more they did everything
they could it blew up in their face over
and over and there were cycles of abuse
and suffering that just kept happening
one of them somehow retains this
i don't know i don't even think it's a
strength of will or something conscious
instinctively she
retains that yearning to connect
and hope um and in the other one it's
quashed
i don't think it's her fault
and to me the film is the difference but
i don't really think i can define any
words
it's one of those
uh as far as i think that the ending was
very well done because it leaves you
with so many thoughts and
just like piecing it out for yourself
like and also comparing it to your own
life these two
these two characters feel like
people in life you know they're witches
but they feel like people that we know
and they feel like ourselves
so it's like well what would i be the
maria or the novena or the novena would
i give up would i be so
despondent that my village tried to burn
me
that i would give up i might
right
i've had all of these thoughts
you can empathize with her so much right
um i hope so i mean i sort of um the
characters came to me together kind of
thing um before i even thought of what
the connection would be
um
um so i don't know like i mean i know
maria is sort of traditionally what
would be seen as an antagonist but
i wrote her backstory in terms of like
it all came kind of not in order you
know it was moments and things that
somehow i tried to shape into a story in
a hurry in a particular moment
for like a deadline i had for like a
story workshop
um but the very first sequence there was
her backstory so that was the context
with which i worked that whole time um
and then i realized it didn't quite fit
in the beginning and i sort of thought i
would save it
for what what is kind of emotionally the
midpoint because i feel like that's when
you sort of
need to deepen
uh that's the opportunity to really
deepen a world and a story and i felt
like that's where
it actually almost like transplanted
itself so neatly it was kind of
um
surprising and a relief because i didn't
know if it would work but um
i i always started from a place of
empathy with her um
and like that's when i cried the most
really she made me cry more than any
others on set so yeah
maria's performance yeah yeah
it's it's fantastic she's
so expressive even with all the you know
the burn makeup on
um she's such a great physical actor
um you can really see everything
still play across her face even though
she has all the prosthetics on
um
so we have a lot of uh first time
um
or budding filmmakers who are members of
film independent
if you
think back to
um making this film
is there anything that you wish that
anybody would have told you
before you started making this film
it's any sort of advice that you would
give to somebody entering
a project
um
to be honest he was eerily a dreamlike
experience there was i mean other than
you know avoid children and animals but
really you should know that
like yeah on day two of shooting when
we're you know filming a very intense or
starting to film a very intense
emotional scene when the goats burst out
of their
enclosure halfway through the take and
run into the mountain and we have the 70
year old shepherds chasing them across
the mountain for half an hour and it's
raining like that's the moment that i'm
like yeah no no more goats no more
babies
but a lot of it is just really basic
practical things but you had a lot of
animals and kids in this i'm aware yes
yes that's the advice i didn't think
cgi children
and animals
yeah
genuinely that's the smart i mean a lot
of it really was
an eerily positive experience i mean
genuinely all of us kind of felt like so
lucky to be living it out because it
felt like we were living you know this
story out and we were connected as
people and you know to the story world
that we're hoping the film is good but
it was already kind of worth it you know
so
i was just happy to be making a movie
you know it's been 20 years i've been
you know writing and directing shorts
and writing but non-directing
features
um so it was hard to really feel badly
or negatively about anything or even and
also don't remember like i keep
forgetting i actually dislocated my knee
two days before the shoot i was embraced
the whole time enough to keep running up
and down the mountains and limping um
but i forget about that
now i forget about that i think if you
asked me like during the shoot i
probably would have had a lot of advice
but now it's all lovely positive memory
um i had an indie filmmaker tell me one
time because he had chosen to make a
horror film for his first feature he
felt like
that was the only thing
that people wanted him to do after that
if you
do you
uh feel like you you will keep um
staying in the horror genre or do you
think i already made my second film it's
a grungy gay love story he said in the
90s in melbourne gay love story
is it very different
is it edited can we see it yeah i mean
it's in sound mix the reason i could
come here is because the sound editor is
just assembling so that i can fly in for
the sound mix two weeks from now it's
it's premiering at the melbourne film
festival in a few months
and coming here i can't reveal the
details but you will be getting a
theatrical release oh congratulations
yeah it's crazy
um and then i i'm shooting a third film
in macedonia in july i mean
it's hard to plan anything happening in
europe right now obviously but um
technically that's you know still going
um
going well at the moment um while the
world is falling apart so it's a very
strange feeling
um
i i sort of never really thought of and
i have like a stack of stories i'm very
connected to that i want to make i'm not
really
i haven't even been really taking many
meetings in terms of
people sending me stuff because i have
the stories i want to tell and i have my
team now as well and um
so i think i'm now more open to
exploring
genre premises and
i have one that's kind of a ghost story
that i've written
um
but i and i
you know more will hopefully come to me
now because i'm not really thinking with
limits when i'm right now and the way it
used to
but
um
yeah i think people want to send me
stuff about witches or zombies or
shape-shifters or things but
i have a very good agent who doesn't let
me
deal with that
i got a witch script for you i'll give
it to you after this
you gotta pass i actually i don't i have
an ancestor who was hanged as a witch
but i
okay i've not written the script about
it so don't worry but if you do that one
i'm curious about now you know
what's really crazy is i had an a i
found out i had an ancestor that was
hanged as a witch and then i found out
that one of my best friends from college
was descended from someone who killed
witches okay so i'm writing this script
you don't have to this is let's just
chat
you know this yeah yeah yeah give me
three weeks yeah okay so this comes out
on friday
this one yes sorry number one in
theaters and streaming or theaters first
no theaters just okay
um
fantastic well if you loved this tell
tell everybody um to go see it
especially see it in a theater it's so
magnificent on the big screen so much
better than on my television
and thank you so much for spending some
time with us tonight it was great to
talk to you congratulations
thank you
[Music]